all right what's the definition of
delicates all our students have spent
some time in a refugee camp so some of
our students have seen war and never
been in a school before but kids are
much more resilient and much more
hopeful than adults
coach luma founded the Fugees academies
the only school system for refugees in
the United States for her creating a
school where displaced children to
thrive was very personal
my name is luma muffler I'm CEO and
founder of the Fugees family and I'm an
immigrant from Jordan my name is Minnie
Driver I am an actress a singer and I am
an immigrant I believe nothing is more
American than its immigrants so I'm
teaming up with great big story to
celebrate those that have come here and
left their mark
oh I think giving up my citizenship was
the hardest thing I've ever had to do
I'm gay and Jordan you can get the death
penalty for being gay and the u.s.
allows you to claim asylum to know that
a country you love doesn't want you it's
really hard
coach luma moved to the United States in
college she played soccer growing up so
when she met a group of young refugees
playing the sport it reminded her of
home she decided to form a team for them
that team name was the Fugees we're
reclaiming the word refugee we want to
be proud of it we don't want it to have
the stigma of shame and it's about
finding a common identity for everybody
who's had to leave there good as Lima
grew to love these kids she soon
realized they weren't getting the
attention they needed in the public
school system their parents couldn't
help them with their homework because
most of them hadn't received a high
school education so they would ask luma
for help I quickly realized that if
they've attended public school those
experiences were not positive I said you
know if this was my child what would I
do in 2004 she created a school that
catered to the needs of these children
and she named it the Fugees Academy
looma recruited most of her students on
the soccer field and soon enough news of
the school spread the Fugees academies
represent over 32 different ethnic
groups we can't do bilingual education
because we'd have to have over 30
languages represented the immersion
approach works I think it's actually
easier to teach English to people who
speak different languages because it's
commonality they're also surrounded by
kids that have the same experience and
so they're not gonna be made fun of if
they don't know the language or if they
have an accent and the Fugees academies
take great pride in reaching the kids at
that grade level regardless of their age
in our sixth grade class you'll see us
teaching what would typically be taught
in a kindergarten first grade classroom
and then by seventh grade it's third and
fourth grade and then by eighth grade
they're catching up to grade level our
standard is very high for them because
we know what it takes to make it in this
country
Lumis priority is to break the cycle of
poverty for these families in the United
States we do really talk about the
commonality of having to flee your
country and it's very powerful and what
we're gonna see with their families and
the generations after is going to be
incredible
every year since 2016 over 95% of her
seniors graduate with a high school
diploma a first for most of the families
in the audience I think their graduation
day is a symbol of America for all our
families in some ways this might be the
American dream - Ben I was born in
Anyang in refugee camp in Thailand
my name is harnason eventually we'll be
dr. Hirata son I'm the first in my
family to finish elementary school
middle school high school and now attend
college I'm the first in my village to
make it this far and I'll keep on going
I think it's a very dangerous narrative
to feel sorry for refugees because the
mere fact that they are here shows how
strong they are in 2018 luma opened a
second school in Columbus Ohio
but it's Loomis dream to have a school
in every refugee resettlement hub in the
country if you create opportunities for
them to thrive I mean they're gonna
accomplish the impossible because look
at what they've survived I think that's
what a coach does is like you believe in
the ability of that person may you start
believing that these things are possible
you